[Music]
our own cooking confidence coach nanny
bubbe is back in studio thanks to
chapman automotive the sponsors of this
segment today we're learning how to make
donnie's mac and cheese and we're joined
by a special guest don hamrick the
general manager of chapman automotive
how are you don i'm fabulous jesse how
are you i'm fantastic i i feel like
there's a connection between donnie's
mac and cheese and don hamrick that's
right exactly that's right and also it's
great to put a face to the logo that is
hidden everywhere right the logo is out
we love it guys thank you so we're
making mac and cheese as a side dish for
thanksgiving but we want to talk about
how important these side dishes are
throughout time with our families they
come by through generations and this is
your mother's recipe this is a mom's
recipe for mac and cheese and we kind of
all fell in love with it so there's a
lot of memories baked into this dish and
one of our senses is
is smell and it brings back memories
with a nose like this you think i would
know that um yeah so you know that's the
thing when you your sense of smell
connects you to memories quicker than
anything else so and we're starting
today with a roux right got to make the
rooster so let's talk about a route okay
what is a roux there you go let's start
making butter and flour as we talked
about now donna's been here about an
hour just stirring something by the way
he was just preparing something he's
getting ready we're going to show how it
makes and you have to kind of do it in
like 15 seconds or so but this is six
tablespoons of butter okay and we put in
a half a cup of flour
and what we're going to do is dissolve
the flour i'm going to just turn that up
a little bit donnie and turn that up
just a little bit probably more than i
need to but we don't have the time for
it to totally thicken but once it's
incorporated what you're going to do is
just incorporate that really quickly
there you go there you go and then we're
going to
we're going to pour in the milk and then
that starts to thicken
and you just pour it in little by little
by little slow pour yeah because this is
the key to the basic ingredients of
great mac and cheese all right is a
great roux there you go
now we're doing it here too there's
three of us in the kitchen this is great
bonding too with the family thanksgiving
mom dad whoever in the kitchen cooking
with the kids it creates a bonding
experience for people can't you see
donnie doing this with his mom
absolutely and he pass it down to his
kids as well yes he does speak a little
french for us
well no
mom loved my mac and cheese her mac and
cheese we did together and now my son
so yeah it's a family but this is a
great way too for that family member to
be a part of thanksgiving and holidays
in the future as well with their recipes
so you'll see that that will then blend
in and we're going to turn that off now
we're going to bring everybody's
attention right over here
yeah this is what we've been doing and
it turns like this so let's turn that
off before so this how long are you
stirring this until you get this ah we
were at this for about 10 minutes right
yeah down was working hard at this thing
oh yes we'll leave it it's okay
okay we'll just move it up now it's time
to put the cheeses in okay so we're
going to start first with what uh the
most component half okay what is this
four ounces of marshmallows so is this
the secret recipe the family secrets
this is an italian semi-sweet soft
cheese so give it right now where are we
finding this whole foods sprouts
everywhere yeah
trader joe's trader joe's has a great
mascarpone it gives it an italian cream
cheese is what it really is okay it's
just really fun it's really thick too
this is the secret sauce right here but
it's softer than cream cheese so it's
important okay
see how quickly that melts in yep now we
start mixing in our cheeses so
is our base for the cheese sauce wow so
we got two cheeses in here so far so far
there's gonna be a total of four i'm
going to put in the salt and pepper okay
so about a teaspoon of salt
i actually like
no you guys for thanksgiving i'm more a
fan of the size than the actual turkey i
don't know
i love it everybody says that everybody
says that so there's some pepper and now
we're going to put in white cheddar okay
but before we put in the white cheddar
sharp white cheddar do you know what
this is uh
chocolate nuts no not mac nutmeg
really nutmeg okay are you ready yes
here we go so you got to grind in the
nutmeg the nutmeg is one of the secret
sauces
secret ingredients right there
it's not so good you want that whole
nutmeg in there when you're biting into
it donald there's a tooth no no there
you go there you go
no definitely not okay so we've got
about 45 seconds to go we're going to
put in the white sharp cheddar
incorporate that
beautiful
pull that i love the amount of cheese we
put in this i know it's so good it's mac
and cheese right right yes okay
now we've got putting in the yellow
cheddar
and then as it goes in
you make this every thanksgiving yeah
yeah and sometimes even before go ahead
fresh pasta okay you ready for this to
go in why not okay one more time just
incorporate that in how we doing on time
j.c uh about less than 30 seconds okay
you put that all in
and incorporate it there you go let's
get this all this is great it just looks
there we go whoa
last time i did this i beautiful me and
watch yourself you want to get that yep
okay i got it you got it here we go the
big reveal everybody everybody start
your forks right over there donnie's mac
and cheese look at that
wow you can smell the cheese it smells
so good perfect excellent you go first
chef first okay
wow bubbly too look at this this is
okay i gotta wrap it up here take a bite
don yep
okay well check out nanny bubby's
kitchen and garden on social media and
online at nannybuggy.com it's so hot
scroll up and i'll continue on
spread love like butter have a wonderful
thanksgiving and thank you to john
hammer from chapman automotive for
sponsoring this segment jillian over to
you
hey thanks for that